il ya une réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il y à un rebond de la délinquance dans
notre pays le bilan des manuels macron
sur la première période sur ses trois
premières années
c'est un bilan d'échec en matière de
sécurité et de questions migratoires
lorsque l'état dépense 1000 euros 25
seulement sont consacrés à la sécu à la
sécurité
4 4 sont vos secrets à la justice voyez
c'est extrêmement faible et ce qui fait
que dans ce domaine avait que 3 % on est
le 22e pays européens sur 27 en matière
d'efforts régalien c'est à dire des
fores de sécurité qu'on se rend compte
que ce n'est pas suffisant c'est pour ça
que nous les républicains nous proposons
c'est d'ailleurs grâce au travail de
christian jacob et des apps des
appréciations des uns des autres on
propose d'évoluer de 0,8 pour cent du
pib pour la sécurité à 1 % sur cinq ans
ce qui est un effort considérable et
puisqu'on parle d'autorité de l'état est
ce que vous estimez dans la gestion du
coronavirus que l'état le gouvernement
manque parfois un peu d'autorité on a vu
les atermoiements sur les masques les
rassemblements qu'on autorise finalement
puis qu'on autorise plus est-ce qu'il ya
quand même un peu de flottement cabieu
le stade parce que c'est pas flottement
est un désastre
vous savez vous avez vous la gestion du
cours de violences par le gouvernement
est un désastre
la gestion des crises il était incapable
de gérer la crise des gilet jaune se
terminent tous en queue de poisson
incapable de gérer la crise sanitaire
joue avec là aussi on a un organisme
international qui a observé les 32 pays
du continent européen
on classe 26e 27e pour la médiocrité de
la manière dont on gère ces crises il
coûtait il y avait une ligne sanitaires
à avoir c'est à dire 1 il fallait tester
eal2
il fallait protéger avec les masques le
sujet serait pas aussi grave que ce
matin et après sur les cuisses de rire
quand on entend le goût vers le les
mêmes les mêmes qui nous explique
aujourd'hui que les entreprises doivent
faire des stocks de 10 semaines de
masquer les mêmes nous expliquer que
l'ema ça servait à rien pu écouter on
est dans dans quel monde et
et ensuite il faut isoler et soigner là
aujourd'hui à cette réalité la pandémie
dans le monde continue à se développer
en france le virus commence à circuler
et 3e réalité il n'ya ni vaccin ni
médicaments il ya donc incapacité de
gérer la crise des gilets jaunes yeah
yeah ça s'est terminé en queue de
poisson incapacité à gérer cette crise
sanitaire est en réalité je crains hélas
incapacité à gérer la crise économique
qui qui s'annonce vous savez quand on a
une chute de 40% des à deux
investissements quand on a un taux de
chômage qui a augmenté de 25 % sur un
trimestre quand on sait qui va sept cent
mille jeunes qui vont arriver à la
rentrée sur marché du travail sept cent
mille jeunes diplômés et qu'on ne sait
pas quoi leur donner oui effectivement
il ya de quoi être inquiet vers que vous
faites c'est un constat juste